من احد مراكز الاختراع في الكويت مراسله
الجزيره سمر شدياق سمر نتابع ماكي مسار
العمليه الانتخابيه حتى اللحظه
نعم ازدهار حقيقه نتحدث بعد مرور نحو ثلاث
ساعات واربعين دقيقه من انطلاق العمليه
الانتخابيه هنا في الكويت في هذه
الانتخابات التي يقترع فيها الكويتيون
للمره الثانيه في اقل من عام وتحديدا خلال
تسعه اشهر يقترع الكويتيون وينتخبون
برلمان جديدا ويختار الكويتون اليوم
ممثليهم الخمسين في هذا البرلمان المشهد
الانتخابي الصباحي كان مختلفا للاجواء
الهادئه التي تسيطر الان هنا في الدائره
الثالثه حيث اقف امام احد مراكز الاقتراع
هذه الساحه تعج بمندوبي المرشحين وبمتطوعي
من جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الا ان الفتره
الصباحيه كان هناك اقبال لافت اقبال ملحوظ
واقبال مبكر للشباب ولكبار السن هذه
الاجواء الهادئه الان ربما هي معتاده في
كل استحقاق انتخابي خاصه هنا في الكويت
على اعتبار بان السلطات حد هذا اليوم يوم
راحه هذا اليوم هو يوم عطله رسميه ليتمكن
الكويتيون من التصويت بكل اريحيه وممارسه
حقهم الانتخابي الا ان هناك خشيه بان يمتد
هذا الهدوء المسيطر حاليا خصوصا وان نسبه
الاقتراع بلغت بعد مرور ثلاث ساعات من
انطلاق العمليه الانتخابيه هنا في هذا
المركز نحو 10% فقط من اجمالي الناخبين
هناك خشيه بان ينسحب هذا الهدوء طوال
اليوم الانتخابي خاصه بان هناك حاله من
الياس والاحباط تتملك بعض الفئات في
الكويت نتيجه تكرار العمليه الانتخابيه
نتحدث عن ثالث عمليه انتخابيه تجري في
غضون عامين ونصف هذه هي سابع انتخابات في
غضون 10 سنوات اصبح هناك مللا لدى بعض
الفئات والذين يعتبرون بانه لم يعد هناك
جدوى من المشاركه في العمليه الانتخابيه
على اعتبار بان كل البرلمانات السابقه لم
تقدم اي انجاز يعود بالفائده يعود
بالفائده لمصلحه الوطن والمواطنين لذلك
يؤمل وكما علت اصوات عديده خلال الايام
الماضيه تحث الجميع على المشاركه في هذه
الانتخابات خصوصا وان صوره البرلمان
المقبل سيتحدد مش المشهد السياسي على
الساحه البرلمانيه ان برئاسه البرلمان او
حتى بمستوى التعاون مع الحكومه
في الكويت مراسله الجزيره سمر شدياق شكرا
جزيلا لك